all right good so people joining the
livestream we are talking about RDF and
SPARQL capabilities in the upcoming
version of language so let's just get a
sense of what we're gonna cover here
um Koenig so the idea is that this time
it could look at the query language
itself and this design that we have done
for it but to remind ourselves I
prepared a small overview of all the
capabilities and then in the second
section we can look at a query language
in detail that's going great okay so
these are I don't think I've seen these
guide pages these are your guide pages
yes yeah
so from these three guide pages you can
reach all symbol and format ref pages
tell me okay
why's that capitalized he has this gone
through DQ a
they are looking into it fun okay
boy okay all kinds of stuff here all
right um
what is the analog of sparkle select in
SQL world
I know that select in SQL but what is it
in our SQL in our database integration
system I mean the equivalent of this
layer we are not document that is let
not now but okay
fair enough yeah there is that there's a
thing called database like field we use
internally it's it's really just for us
right now a common target for
computation of the queries okay all
right fine okay
when daughter's head comes also that
will compile to that okay all right so
now first question is sort of the big
picture what are people going to be able
to do with this what what's the what's
the pitch for this why do we know so the
in the overview I explained four
different scenarios in which you can use
sparkle one are in memory RDF data that
you can query the second one is you have
a sparkle any point either remote or
local on your machine the third one
would be varying entities and the fourth
one varying relational databases using
sparkle but the last two points are
future okay so wait a minute so how does
this relate to what we're doing with the
database integration project so this
project is based partially on the neo
database integration project at least on
the intermediate layer okay but why do
we care about this this is to use the
query language of sparkle on a
relational database is that the I do yes
and it will become apparent why that
might be useful if once we review the
whole career language because it's in
some sense simple and the mental model
in which you think about these carries
is different so it might be easier for
people to write a sparkle query than a
sequel career but wouldn't it make more
sense if we did that at the end he layer
level so you also possibility but in
this particular case I'm using art Armel
which is a standard
yeah but what I was saying is just that
if we invent entity level primitives
that correspond then to a sparkle
primitive and then the sparkle primitive
correspond to odd to an SQL primitive
then we just go and translate through
these steps okay so this piece of heart
1l well let's come to that a minute okay
so here's a trivial question why isn't
there a mouse-over of this entity
um I don't know I can look into it okay
but there should be right yes the input
form should be there okay
all right okay
so what is this this is a sparkle query
against the entity's system yes how does
that work
well the idea is that entity data can be
viewed as a triple graph in the sense
that you have an entity and the property
thereof and their associated value so
these are naturally some triples and
then effectively you're creating that
graph and applying that query to the
graph but internally it's going more
efficient in some cases okay but when
you write entity isotope are you really
intending entity class size drop one no
it's about the type which has more
information than the class itself
because it has type information that's
not a single entity in any sense no it's
not a single entity correct okay so
let's take it from the top then okay so
in memory RDF so what is this this is a
particular database oh it's just some
data found on the Internet
Library of Congress published some
classification systems and one of them
is about genres if you want to evaluate
these things maybe you could evaluate
the things in common namespaces so these
are explained explain this so these are
things out there on the web that happen
to have IR eyes yes
so each resource and each property is
identified by an eye-fi and to not write
them out all the time I included some
short forms okay so okay what are these
prefixes they are used later you could
evaluate them too yeah okay how do you
get in it alright okay so now let me try
to understand what an earth this is
so for example let's say I take this RDF
graph okay so - what would happen if I
for example wanted to visualize this
graph
des in general tricky
I have strong if implemented I started
implementing something but it's not
ready okay so what if I wanted to get
the entities in here somehow so you
would write a sputter query okay I get
the triples for example there are only
4,000 triples so how would I just show
all of them you could apply edge list to
dead body of cross okay so that's well
if I say vertex list of the genre graph
here so this thing is a graph it's a
bonafide graph is that correct
it's an RDF graph and I'm not sure if he
should be reusing the graph
functionality for in deadweight like you
just did so even that's not technically
a call for the hyper call it is a
hydrograph right I understand so for
example if I say connect find what is
the thing for finding connected
components okay okay all right so this
particular IRI what is RDF Lange's
string it's a language tech string well
it's not mean so that means the first
argument is a string and a sync document
is a language tech like English or
German but why is that a funny name that
isn't one of our types of names so there
so it's it's one name I proposed and we
can use a different one it's not gonna
make it it's not gonna make it a little
thing with a Lang in it it's not gonna
make it um so it's as close to the
standard as possible but yeah we can
choose a different well well if we're
gonna call it a language why don't we
just call it an RDF strain
and and then this language then why
don't we say language arrow English if
we're going to canonicalize that way and
what is this ah D F blank node what are
all these things so so if I say let me
just do
you
oops that's really weird oh whoops it's
not right thing is it
okay so alright so we've got a few rogue
creatures here yes
so these blank notes so first of all
each of these higher eyes they are nodes
in the graph but sometimes you might
want to introduce a node that is needed
to connect certain pieces but that you
don't want to identify that's what you
use these wavelength nodes for so they
are just identifiers that are just
meaningful inside that graph but not on
set okay well so I mean that's a weird
name okay
also I get a standard name yes I
understand but but we're not doing that
I mean we're trying to map these things
into our own structure right in the
future this is kind of more sparkles
representation in our link yeah I know
but we need to not we need to spell out
the words and things
and I don't know what a blank noticed
since we have a thing called blank in
our language
right so if you describe a little bit
more what it is that we can I mean I
don't know what that what is beef or is
that some that that's its name somehow
yes that's an internal identifier that's
just scope to that graph and blank
refers to the fact that it doesn't have
a global identifier
so why isn't it some kind of local I
don't know what that should be but
that's clearly not the right name um
okay so let's keep going here I mean
show me something where it would really
where it's really like oh wow this is
useful type thing rather than toy
examples is there some case where we can
see something on the web where we can
say you know wow we can really use this
I can think of cases where we are using
it internally where it's extremely
useful but I can't really sling out
examples right and right right this
moment but we're using this in we have a
local wiki data mirror that is
constantly updating and so we're using
Sparkle queries to determine people who
have died in the past week
Abed that dates updated in the past week
or past month as well as you know other
properties have been updated for them
Lucas
banner is in the process of making the
people data scraper that runs regularly
use this Sparkle entities this wiki data
entities stored that I've set up okay so
the wiki data what other what other
useful Sparkle things are there out
there dbpedia pedia that's another
wikipedia thing and there are there are
many other tony is the name like oh is
that what I'm thinking of where it's
kind of a federation of ontology that
includes dbpedia and wikipedia and
several linguistics based oncology's
connecting word meanings and such in
different languages through an RDF
triple store and making it all Sparkle
queryable so what I mean we've already
got a bunch of that capability I don't
know what we've got you know that our
dictionaries are becoming hopefully
better than any other dictionaries that
are out there yeah okay
all right fine all right so this is this
is the continuing concern with this
stuff I mean hopefully there is some
actual you know commercial customers out
there who have this stuff and care about
it and hopefully we will be able to use
this technology internally for some
purposes we are definitely using it
internally for purposes and it was
streamlined a lot of work
close okay that's good all right it is
really worked well for us okay
so odd Sparkle property pause so this is
so bonus the sparkle select takes as a
first argument a graph pattern and graph
parents are defined recursively and one
of the possible elements of a graph
garden is a property path that has a
start and an end and a list or a pattern
of visited properties yes okay so for
goodness sake let's just call this RDF
string if we want to do that make sense
and this quotes en we can support that
but I think we should also support
language arrow entity English does that
make sense
yes okay I not even gonna guess what a
Sparkle inverse property is and this
thing here was one of those things that
was a specific was that an IRI
this is one of the commonly used brief
prefixes or at least in debt particular
ontology yeah so Mads of a string is the
name space III together with that local
name okay okay Sparkle variable why do I
need that sparkle variable for the
sparkle select how is the first argument
I'm totally confused here so the first
argument has a number of in scope
variables and the solutions are
basically ways in which this variable
can be replaced such that the pattern is
a sub graph of the whole graph okay all
right so let's let's understand what
this wouldn't normally be this would be
some kind of graph um if we had a graph
pattern that would be that variable
thing would be something where there's a
sub graph and it's named X and we're
getting that X out that correct yes okay
in very different pattern structure than
we would normally have I mean this is
this is the equivalence of parent :
you know blank sparkle blank so to speak
yeah it would be parent underscore and
it's not too dissimilar to solve
yes sense solve you said yeah yeah okay
well we're trying to right but but the
way this is working this is a property
path here and that simply contains the
variable and it's asking us to basically
I mean this this might better be named
something like
this is implicitly finding those things
which are in those things which are
variables in this part so it's finding
all paths with respect to and it doesn't
have to say with respect to some where
where is it describing
the graph so it's it's saying
as part of this sequence here yes so
maybe it's clearer once we review the
syntax later but to start we are
starting at the label tango music then
we are going backwards the label
relation to get the I to get to the note
of that
yeah tango music thing and from that we
go to the broader concepts and once we
reach the broader concept we take that
label again so this is this is doing as
many broadenings as necessary
so why are the three arguments sqr
Sparkle property peratt path has why is
this in a list and the other argument
list because the first argument is
something that's appearing the subject
position the last argument appears in
the object position that means the first
and assert argument of a triple vial the
inner sings I can go in and go as many
as many links as it wants
yes in that sense a it would be quite
different from entity property path
yeah I mean so this is a okay this is an
arbitrary triple which is being called a
property path here and you're
essentially saying you're putting this
variable in here I could put a variable
in anywhere here is that correct yes and
our implementation we can have a
variable anywhere in sparkle you can
have variable in the first in the last
document but not in a property position
okay all right but anyway so you've
you're able to solve for that variable
basically yeah okay okay so this is
rossbach oh yes so the point is that you
can use either too symbolic or the
string version of the Clarys
interchangeably this is presumably
rather trivial to implement yes the
sparkle query thing suppose one executes
one yes right so okay
I have a question about this query those
seem to be both pictures of Mont Blanc
is there a way to say that you only want
one picture picture per Vermont income
yes but that would make the query much
more complicated and distract from okay
so where is the this question mark image
thing what is is that I understand why
this thing decided the sparkle variable
was called image is it this one here
no there every question mark text is a
variable in sparkle and the translator
to sparkle variable of that text okay
well why isn't it solving for the other
variables select and then a sequence of
variables projects to these variables
that means the others are no little bits
variable that's being solved for you can
also put a start here and you can you
get all
here so - I have a question mark star oh
just stop just to start
what am I getting
that's amazing why is that number of so
high precision it's it's still to be
fixed okay
there's currently yeah desk as a not so
easy to represent all of the data types
of RDF in the Wolfram language okay why
was this is low now yeah it's taking the
key data about 3.5 seconds at least the
last time I tried it's not on our side
like this but we have a mirror of what
he day - yes
yes we did we have to one which updates
pretty instantaneously the other one
updates very slowly it so what these
queries we couldn't principle do against
our own mirrors yes yes
so in principle just a URL has to be
replaced
okay okay all right okay so in the
second example just shows in place of a
string you can use a symbolic query but
it's not an interesting curry just a
show okay
but so if I said in here some if I want
to say um I don't know what these
triples actually are doing but but give
me give me a case where
was limit too I understand this limit
why isn't it called max items
limiting there's limit an offset
following the standard okay but we you
know what are we doing here I mean I
don't know why we're even bothering you
know we could just use this syntax if
we're just gonna you know map everything
into why are we bothering I mean I
thought we were trying to make this so
that it was actually you know something
you know it's friendly to our language
in which case this will be max items and
it's we don't have an offset concept but
we could certainly you know I think that
might be useful general concept it's
related to take we will have a course
and I'm well aware
yeah right so I mean we could do that as
part of max items actually we could have
max items start a really an interesting
idea for in general to have that be a
list with an offset but in a case I mean
you know okay so what's an example here
of where I can do something interesting
what can I put in to this property
element here to like I don't know what
what what do I put in here to get this
do something interesting
well a big data you could look up
their properties and then find some
interesting okay so well actually this
isn't Sparkle execute so how would I
look up their properties not using
Sparkle execute yes you would have you
would have to go to that documentation
whose documentation Nikki why doesn't it
why doesn't it have a discovery
interface though that was the whole
point of this kind of thing why can't I
just look up its properties but just by
going into the audio structure you can
also write a query that gives you the
properties that it has
okay but I mean can I write a symbolic
query easily
yes yes you can modify that query
add another option distinct goes to true
and
project to the variable Y as well not on
our live stream somebody is asking why
not just add hypergraph and graph query
backed by Titan or some hyper graph
database because if we add hyper graph
we'd love to add hyper graph one day but
there will be a boatload of things that
we have to do to support hyper graphs in
a serious way I mean I don't know I mean
how we even thought about Michael can
you comment on that have we even thought
about what it would take to support
hyper graphs in a in a useful broad way
I think Walter and Charles we had some
discussion but not in any comprehensive
way okay
I mean it's also not clear I don't know
how canonical kind of the the things one
does with hypergraphs are relative to
graphs okay in any case let's let's keep
going here I'm I'm I want to get into
the syntax and so on I'm giving you a
little bit of a hard time here for the
same reason I have in the past which is
that I just you know it's wonderful to
have all this capability I just you know
I hope that there are real users for it
that's a quick preview on how you could
query entities alpha and okay so this
one so how did we manage to do this I
mean in other words is this a sparkle
enabled version of our and truth or is
this simply you operating this stuff
with respect to an existing mapping this
stuff into our existing entity store
capabilities so implementation wise
alpha didn't get any new capabilities so
it's the web being evaluated on the
client site but it's trying to minimize
the data it has to download to correctly
match that graph button but this is not
done yet it's not fast enough so that's
why it's for a future
it's probably I mean to my eyes it looks
weird that you're mixing let's say two
layers of abstraction
I think fulness once you define how an
entity domain should look as an RDF
graph then you're fine I guess
here's a here's a query what are the two
layers
well one is the entity layer and one is
the sparkle layer I mean at least from a
from the point of view of sequel we kind
of had similar constructs that are much
closer to zero than twenties but you
strictly cannot operate our entities so
all the entity queries compiled to this
layer but the layer doesn't know or care
about entities okay let me ask another
question here okay
what is the impressive thing that one
can do for you know as a result of the
symbolic mapping of sparkle that one
couldn't just do by writing sparkle
queries
so the point is that you can write
programs um that look still elegant then
the whole thing started when I try to
beg some entity store buy a sparkle end
point and I had to do a lot of strange
choice which was ugly and even to get
the simplest thing I had to write a page
of code instead you can have a nice
clean thing separated into small
sanctions and I had no to such programs
you've written a few or you had two to
two new slightly bigger ones but for
what one one is for visualization of all
EF graphs which is not ready yet and the
other one is an importer of an RDF based
format that means the whole information
of the format is encoded as an audio
graph and then you use sparkle to
extract it and these sparkle queries are
monsters but because of the symbolic
representation the code is still nice
and readable
okay all right and these two queries
here that you see using alpha and the
entity store they are both constructed
so that you can see those are things
that are not easily doable with our
current entity capabilities
unless I can see that but I mean but
what we've hoped for okay so so let's
look at this so I don't know if I can
really run this in a reasonable way okay
so this is saying there is a sequence oh
wow okay so this is downloading every
isotope not every it's a little bit
optimized but I'm still working on
making it better why doesn't that engage
with next caching framework
I don't technical reasons that I am
planning to look into okay all right but
so let's take a look at what this is
doing this is essentially a thinking you
know it's essentially a graph pattern
that says you start from Mercury 204 you
end up you can do as many door daughter
nuclides as you want and then I don't
quite understand what this is doing this
is just saying at the end so this is
saying that a key chain of mercury 204
well let me try something a little bit
more interesting let's try the decay
chain of uranium 235 okay
I wonder if I type u-235 is it gonna
work as it can think it's a submarine
okay so that is a long decay chain okay
that's pretty nice
so I see so this is so let me understand
this that what this did here so what
this is doing is it's saying consider
the entity property thing as a as a link
in a graph and now I mean but if we were
going to do this in our own syntax I
would have expected something slightly
different I mean I would have expected
this is a pattern you know what's
happening here is that you know
essentially f of X of X of X of X this
is the case of this is the case we don't
have which is the nested nested function
application right I mean so in other
words if we had a list we would be able
to say X dot and that would match any
you know xxxxX type thing right yeah um
and but but this which is essentially
what's happening here we don't have and
we've talked about that what did we what
have we thought of a think of calling
that Michael do you remember I was not
in such a meeting okay but were we to
have such a thing then what this would
be in effect is because this thing is if
I take you to 35 you know clearly what
I'm doing here an entity property land
is to say this thing of
wherever it is ah how do I pick that
creature up what is going on here
I'm trying also to clicker it there we
go um
okay so this would then give that
interesting that it interesting that
this didn't get hung up on the missing
vet what did that mean
variable I see it's a variable okay
that's because you 235 undergo
spontaneous fishing I mean sorry for the
physics moment but I assume that's the
reason does Michael have a comment on
that
I do not know event why I think I think
it does spontaneous fishing I have a
different different output but but so
that missing didn't tangle up the
sparkle query for some reason yes the
reason is well we could talk about that
design but that's why it's still in the
future considered as a future feature so
the thing is dead this property Dada no
plates returns a list of things and in
our if you would usually represented as
a list of triples so you would have
three times uranium various times in the
subject position this uranium-235 in the
predicate position this property and
then one of these values and you can I'm
not keeping the missings but it might be
possible to keep by the way this is a
it's interesting that this problem has
two Coreys two problems have two
corresponding problems in in plain cycle
which is one the way that missings are
propagated is slightly different from in
the Wolfram language and to that there
is a normal form and that's different
from the one of the entries okay that we
also have this thing like we cannot
represent lists of things yes right but
that's a sequel weirdness yeah but it's
similar here as well you you never have
at least valued property you have
several properties you can write okay
all right fine I think I'm beginning to
understand that all right so let's go
down here um all right now you're going
to talk about the query language boy oh
boy oh boy this is really horrifyingly
complicated this is a quick overview of
all Sparkle features and it contrasts
posters query string verses to symbolic
representation okay so to see which
feature which maps into which okay so
this is the raw sparkle query and this
is saying sparkle select of an audio
triple of
[Music]
what is X that that's some IRI example
but the IRI is that yeah this thing is
just an IRI subscripted with has father
is that correct yeah it's basically that
IRI that you see there I'm using this
example oh it's got a string
concatenation in the IRI yes why is it
that you don't have a subscript that you
don't have a sub dally for the IRI which
does the string concatenation fact that
will be an interesting idea for URLs
potentially as well so my idea would be
if that's what you always end up wanting
to do if is that string concatenation
why not simply make it that this IRI
with a string here concatenates that
string into the you know into the form
of the of the effectively URL
is that an obviously stupid idea for URL
by the way
per URL but just maybe you're missing
the point but it's just way quicker to
type e^x as father oh no no okay
like there is one thing they not
convinced I mean when you compare these
the sparkle query with the with the
sparkle select in the sparkle query you
have a way to define prefixes at the
beginning and I would say I mean and
then and then you give them a short name
so why don't you have a two argument
version of IRI
and in the select some kind of header
that defines what the first argument is
that's exactly what I had before but I
removed that design because it led to
the possibility that people use two
different ways of shortcutting sings and
it turned out that what you've just
proposed actually clutter the code more
than using these short prefixes
so I actually removed this non feature
or unsee okay listen one thing I want to
talk about maybe we can get this sent to
an LCC or an Ald meeting is this idea
just had of having this kind of sub
value mechanism for all of these things
including things like file that would
allow you to basically just go and you
know it's just a way of adding a a piece
to the park am I making sense well for
files it might make sense because they
are pass urls are not passed and
sometimes you don't wanna like you want
to add size do we have a project manager
in this meeting no we don't okay could
you make sure that that gets forwarded
to those guys okay so my claim is that
useful thing for URLs would be just
string join because sometimes you okay
let's not let's not do that in this
discussion it's just an idea that we
could put on the shelf for later okay so
I want to try to understand okay so
there's a filter here
so that's the
okay
I don't understand okay so that's part
of hey III that's part of the pattern
that is a select you can also put the
condition directly next to the triple
mr. year in it
so both is fine
we took a slightly different path here
we have a different head that does the
wear which is the lobby's where it's
like it's internal but like we don't
overload an existing the existing
condition thing so I try to reuse or
from language features whenever they
were basically a correct match for that
feature like in the case of alternatives
which stands for Union
or an extent it's why it's optional not
what optional can wrap any other pattern
in this case just a triple pattern why
isn't it just the the Wolfram language
optional pattern construct because
optional behaves a little bit unexpected
then just use purely for pattern
matching I had discussed about report
you need to have a function and define a
default and since I get so admit it's
probably wrong with supported directly
in pure parapatric some years ago where
we discussed it I mean I learned very
early on to use repeated 0 1 instead of
optional
yeah exactly which is ok can we discuss
that and LCCC meeting please could you
bring that up again
Thanks ok
Sparkle select
yeah you match the pattern only if the
other pattern doesn't exist and so on
here this property pass their barriers
construct and they can be nested okay
look this stuff is really complicated I
mean what okay what do we think is going
to be the flow here do we think there
are things where we can translate
natural language into the stuff and get
something useful for both now for type
queries or what
there are some projects out there that
do natural language yeah yeah yeah I'm
not interested in the toys is there
something we actually think we can do
that I mean that we can't do right now
that this will allow us to do
using crime I think definitely
krishna's only did
this complicated commute that can be
expressed in the language are not too
common clearly so it's not obvious if
the effort is justified to do it right
well right and I mean that's the
question is that that's what I'm still
pushing on is I'm just trying to
understand okay so I mean you know this
doesn't look so hard to read this
sparkle query so what you know again
what's the example so you're saying if
you want to if you want to construct
this programmatically it's obviously
much easier to use a symbolic structure
this is to use you know of just a string
I I guess in yeah I found various in
Internet where people are exploring ways
to construct sparkle strings and I think
this is the solution because you can
convert from and to sparkle strings okay
how do you convert from this sparkle
string to this symbolic representation
import string of debts income a sparkly
okay so concluding the prefixes okay
because otherwise prefixes are not
defined okay
all right so if I take this and I say
okay so let me get that there shrimp
okay and now I say import string of that
thing comma sparkle query
that right yes interesting okay what a
sparkle constructor that's the same
thing you had there
well that's round trip but very cool
yes they do round trip from after a few
things after if you want they stabilized
you
okay it looks a little bit longer
because you didn't specify the prefixes
but you can have an option their
prefixes close to and then you have two
short form again but it's a detail
that's documented that's interesting I
mean this is interesting okay
so again in terms of constructing the
sparkle query I mean what do we think
that the source for constructing an
Sparkle query will typically be other
than people writing you know their own
code to do it
well in my case it was always me coming
up as it because it might be really
tricky to come up with the right queries
so I build it piece by piece you mean by
source of to clearly isn't it clearly
not always something that's very
subjective and yes I understand but the
point is people understanding because
there is a dearth of actual Sparkle
sources out there you know I'm trying to
understand I mean like like is does some
does NIH you know that some of these
government entities seems like they they
were at least talking years ago about
having oh everything's gonna be an odd
EF something or other did that happen I
mean people particularly the government
sector for you know triple stores and
things I mean that's what it's for
you know mesh the NIH has done a bunch
of Sparkle stuff is has the Library of
Congress and other similar agencies
agencies and handlers handle similar
data in the government have indeed gone
and made Sparkle endpoints for their
assorted vocabularies and and so I think
I think top Kim has yes I think you're
right I like playing with some kind of
Library of Congress Sparkle end point
and it has was quite brain dead I mean
that is it was heavily throttled and it
wasn't clear what the point was yeah
Library of Congress doesn't have one
anymore I have running on my Linux box a
try to Library of Congress Park line
points right now yeah that came from
that were what earlier Library of
Congress products known from downloading
the triples from them their download
site that you looked at way at the
beginning of the meeting and then
loading them into a a triple story
engine and then just pointing
Mathematica Sparkle select to that end
point so we are not planning to have our
own triple store engine is that true or
not true
I would love it if it were true I may
think that's more to me I'm not sure if
I understand the question there this we
have an engine we have a full
implementation of sparkle but maybe you
mean we won't have a sparkle end point
that even means to fuse for the engine
not the entrances no actually I was
asking about itself okay so great so
like in the case of SQL we don't have
you know we don't have a local SQL
engine we're using the external SQL
engine engine yes um we have a local
engine yes so these curves that you see
there Peter - symbolic or the query
string you can apply it directly to an
audio graph like the example above and
it will work so this is evaluating okay
okay so wait a minute so the RDF graph
so one of the things you've done is
you've got import you know formats for
the various things that are out there so
do you have all of the things that
people like a dot RTF file or something
is that now in portable yeah we have six
importers the most important ones like
turtle or the F XML chasin LD cool and
and that is importing into this
framework is that correct or like an RDF
what is it important - it is returning
in an RDF graph or an RDF data set
now this what is it what is an RDF graph
is that a one of our ordinary graphs or
is that something different another F
graph has had RDF graph and it's
basically which is it's some kind of
hyper graph ultimately is that correct
yes order something like that
okay well generically can be it doesn't
have to be a hyper cough but but given
that object it is then plausible to
process it with standard Wolfram
language functions and make a graph that
you can visualize and all that kind of
thing is that the idea so you can look
at graph documentation and there are two
examples where you should show a
possible conversion to and from a graph
you said ODF graph yes in the properties
and relations so this converts a graph
so yeah this output is still wrong it
should be bigger the out one
so this disk converts an RDF graph to
graph and properly fill its the graph
specific or so which is now going to be
an annotation
you
yeah if you can assume that graph of the
upper bigger than you see what 17 death
can you keep normal
of what of RDF graph to graph no because
the different ways in which you might
choose to represent it
you
okay so what's the converter then sorry
what was the zoom here on this thing
okay okay okay um so it's it's tricky to
cook to encode the rdf information in a
nomogram object right okay
so again just zooming out for a second
so you know the places where this is
going to be valuable are people
customers others who have large existing
triple stores
that true or be more people who use
large existing stores which tell me
which ones there are because so far
you're not you're not convincing me on
that the weather is more popular which
the latter thing Michael said there
there so what long as the people are
using there's the ones that we've
covered so far okay so there's the
Library of Congress which closed it down
that's okay so that's one strike down
okay
there's wiki data which is alive okay
what else is that I'm going to send you
a link in messenger of thing okay
interests pub camp what aspect of
pubchem is interesting for our purposes
that we haven't looked yet okay okay um
I mean do we believe you know I know in
past years they've been customers who
had large triple stores and we're
interested in doing things with them but
I frankly haven't heard about that for a
while
I spoke with Nathan he said years of you
okay alright okay great have they not
shown this a 40 mm eh I don't know okay
somebody's asking whether we have an
analogue of this query service query
help but what is this it's a user
interface for constructing these curries
and no but I'm actually sometimes using
that input to construct example queries
okay looks nice
okay but in principle we could probably
build that although it's not clear given
that given the lack of of them yeah I
was just communicating with a chap who
was responsible for this this page I
believed oh really
cool there's um as Alan observed this is
what I was trying to think of earlier on
when they said like oh there's a lot of
dead sparkline points in there but
plenty of places to download data build
your own sparkle endpoint a good thing
with something Tony hasn't mentioned is
that you can do federated searches
through Sparkle so if you're searching
for something on dbpedia and it has a
wiki data ID you can go in past sure
that's the point of an IRA right that's
exactly the point and so this website
here that we're looking at is showing
all the inner linking amongst all these
different Sparkle endpoints and so
presumably we could regenerate this
picture presumably yes okay and what
fraction of these do we believe are
alive so I mean this is a page that's a
great question and I was really curious
I'm really curious I can huddle how do
we get to
is there an easy way if I just took this
esquina blob it'll take you to a page
that gives you know I understand but I
don't even know how many circles that
are in that picture I'm playing it
Wilson yeah I was I was hoping I could
just for how many 12 24 how do you know
that there's a web page
that is really good counting there's a
version of this that you can report okay
um okay all right so all of those 1224
how many do we think are alive I poked
at a random 10 a little earlier in this
meeting and more than half of them more
than half of the ones that claim to have
open Sparkle links those links were dead
and the ones that were live mostly
seemed to be from from going through the
same separate bioscience portal okay
that's not very encouraging not
promising yes that was that was just
looking at the ones that had sort of
live Sparkle end points there were many
of those did have live links you could
have important you go to download the
holes the whole database you could get
it done now you can put import the JSON
directly from the URL yeah um okay so
okay but so it continues to be my
question you know where is there the
stuff in the wild
I think it's something that really
hasn't settled yet it's the whole dream
of the Semantic Web well aware yeah yeah
hearing this for years right right yes
if I but it seems to be finally gaining
traction some wise Providence that it's
kind of traction just anecdotally just
from communicating with library friends
and such they're they're more interested
in in building data repositories that
are linked to other data repositories
and sharing their data in this way and
Sparkle is the way to query that link
data great well we're doing a service
hopefully they appreciate it
I hope so too I for one so so let's make
sure we get a list of all those people
are so we let them know when we actually
release this sure and that's on let's
hope they care um and if they do then
we'll go on developing it if they don't
then you know if they're uses of us for
our internal purposes great um all right
now look in terms of this design and
we're over time here um it's you know I
know you've put lots of effort into this
so I figured so Michael have you
reviewed all the stuff not everything in
cruciate indeed uh no I I don't think I
mean I think we should just trust Tony
on this because I think this is
something where I mean a couple other
people have looked at it so it's not
that nobody has to run it who else would
end all Steiner Hall went through
everything okay that's one person any
others you know
there is I have one question which is
like something we've been struggling
with with sequel and maybe you have a
better solution what is your like if you
encounter something say in the filter in
the condition that you don't know how to
turn into sparkle what do you do do you
do you fall back into running in my
memory you issue a message so there did
two cases once I if I haven't
my Marie rfgrafton it will just go sue
yeah sure
evaluation if it can't be exported as a
sparkle string then it'll fail okay so
it's and does it tell you like this is
the symbol you're using I don't know how
to translate well counted are no
sophisticated error messages just a
basic rule okay this is what I'm
struggling with right now so I imagine
that you had seen her problem
yeah okay so look what what are we doing
I need to run here but but
well I just had one open design question
we have this idea of graph and RDF data
set and I'm wondering whether we should
just unified it into an RDF store yeah
that's my no idea of hand I mean I I
don't know from what you've told me I
don't have enough information to say
if you think we should you know look
this this is clearly its own separate
world I mean it would be a lot of work I
mean you know we've spent probably mmm
at least 20 hours of design reviews
maybe more grinding the SQL database
integration system into something which
is you know well integrated into the
language and I'm fairly happy with what
we've got now but I I suspect this would
be a similar amount of effort and you
know in the end we would be able to get
something which is better integrated
into the language i mean i i'm curious
how efficient are these triple stores in
other words if we won't want it to do
how efficient is the triple store engine
is it particularly is it really clever
or is it kind of you know nothing
special in terms of being able to find
these parts and so on so it's a very
tricky question because it's hard to
find comprehensive benchmarks there are
good benchmarks for certain areas of
snow obviously generate your own
completely abstract audio f growth yes
but the problem is having the right
distribution and constructing possible
syntax combinations that are useful or
not there are things that test
well basic features of sparkle but i
haven't found any good benchmark for
property pass and i have tested some on
my own and my implementation is faster
on some queries than other stores but
this is just because I know my man
implementation so it's very hard to
correctly judge which one is so the
measure on the space are possible both
hypergraphs
and queries is very unclear I mean like
like we might imagine that there will be
some small world network II thing in the
in the actual graphs of real data in the
world but who knows and you know we can
generate a random graph with various
kinds of distributions but that's you
know who knows whether that's actually
what real in the wild I mean presumably
one could look at the wiki data graph
and ask what its properties are
okay look III think the basic conclusion
here has to be and we probably should
look at this one more time the basic I
would really like to know more about
what's out there in the world and who we
can tell about this and who's likely to
care um and by all means you know I
haven't I haven't chatted with Tim
berners-lee in a while but we can
certainly ask him if he is he still on
this kick do you know
is he still yes very much so
okay my understanding is that he very
much is is still on the semantic web
kick okay and sparkle is some his
fingerprints around here yeah okay um
all right well it'd be really good to
get some more information about who's
likely to care about the stuff um and as
concretely as possible um and also you
know if if the people who care really
are interested in these kinds of
programmatic query generation
or not or whether they mostly just want
to check a box that say yeah we have our
data in a triple store now we can be
happy
um okay but but in terms of what you've
built here I mean it seems like we're
not gonna grind it all the way to have a
full integration this is this is really
if you understand something about
Sparkle then you have a chance of being
able to do this it looks pretty nice for
that and I assume that you're going to
it looks like you've got some reasonable
documentation hopefully you're going to
have some tutorials and things just head
meetings so there's going to be work
clothes that basically say if you've got
a triple store here's how to use it it's
not right things like that or how to
look into a file that you just found
things like that great that's great um
all right what okay I need to go to a
different meeting but I think we should
follow up one more time with this um
also tended incomplete leg and relay
that name train juries any other picker
because changes you want I don't think
it makes any sense because I it's
through it I mean as I'm saying to do a
full full integration is a huge amount
of work and I don't think it's worth it
no there was never the goal no no I
understand I understand I mean the the
goal is what you've done which is to
make a nice symbolic wrapper around
sparkle I'm just you know it's taken
longer than I thought it might um and
you know because there's been all kinds
of issues no doubt I think the things
that we might get out of it are ideas
for how to start dealing with graph
patterns and you know integrated graph
battens in the language that seems like
a useful thing to be able to learn from
this and potentially you know actual
data sources that we can now use which
were Sparkle accessible but that seems
to be honestly apart from wiki data
something of a pipe dream um all right
well fair enough good look this stuff
looks really nice and it's it's a you
know good work all right I'm gonna
disappear thanks to folks on the
livestream um and we've got some other
live streams coming up later today this
is the season of of getting ready for a
big release and live streaming lots of
things so hope to see you all later